[Music]  oh  shoot i'll start mellow okay for the  fashion sense  uh bench zone for sure cut my pops but  it's all love though  that's all my brothers man my brothers  for sure  i can't even pick they all funny in  their own way yeah everybody giving it  dad  yeah him too so everyone's going  everybody's on board for that  i'm a neat freak so i'm for show just  throw me in there just to let y'all know  and then uh my mom keeps the house clean  my pops leather house clean so we can  start that  bench we can bench zone cut mellow for  sure  [Music]  cooking start start my pops for sure yup  easy easy  and my brothers can't cook i'm a bench  myself  and then it don't even matter they both  cut perfect